- 'Cause it's such an amazing thing for,
especially I was a young
girl and played soccer.
Like that's a really cool thing to like,
watch a woman that you idolize.
Like make it, and not just make it,
like bad ass kinda make it.
- [Brandi] You know I think
to answer your question,
It seems difficult.
Like why would somebody
be upset about that?
But I think that the commentary
was they'd never seen
something like that before.
And so that makes people
uncomfortable, right?
And so 99%, let's say 98% was like,
'Oh my gosh, this was the
greatest sporting event
I ever went to',
'I'm so happy that I
got to bring my kids.'
There's always gonna
be someone in your life
or some organization
that doesn't believe in
what you believe in,
or see the things the
same way you see them.
That's an opportunity to
bring people together.
So for me it was like,
let's have a conversation.
- Yeah.
- [Brandi] You know, I did the interviews.
You know, now my granddaughter
wants to take off her top
and you know, you were sexualizing sports.
I mean, Erin, look at her.
She's heard the story already.
(laughs)
But this is what I said.
Come out.
See what we do.
- [Erin] Yes.
- Give it a try.
You'll understand what it's like.
- And you're celebrating.
(audience clapping)
Like it was amazing.
- Listen, in '99 we
were responsible for the
future of women's soccer, right?
(laughs)
And if we didn't win, it
would have all gone away.
- Yeah.
- It would have been like,
'Oh that was cute.'
- You did.
- 'That was sweet.'
- [Erin] Right.
- You ignited the domino
effect with change.
- [Brandi] Yeah, and instead,
you know, that team took on
all that responsibility and
understood how to filter that,
and to do what they do, how
to do, at the right time
and be ready to be champions.
- Yeah.
- That is not easy to do but
they did it at the right time.
- [Kelly] Hard work. Hard work pays off.
- In my opinion, hard work
should be a common denominator.
We all should work hard.
That's, you know, you got that.
- [Kelly] But we all don't.
And that's why only some of
us are champions. (laughs)
- Yeah.